some people that are in the public eye
if there's a paparazzi photo of them
they kind of want it to go away what I
like about you is you actually post it
yourself
they took this paparazzi photo of you at
the airport yeah it's one of the least
flattering photos I've seen of anyone in
a long time there you got a hold of it
and put it out there what's going on in
this photo what happens if you go to the
airport and now there's always paparazzi
there now they are not there for me I'm
just like who's there while they're
waiting for Angelina Jolie yes once once
there was like 20 of them and I got off
the plane and I see them and they're
waiting for someone else and they look
at me like we know who you are and we
don't give a crap and then one guy just
lifts this camera went click yeah I look
but now they asked you questions you
know they it's the guys from what's the
show where they mz4 they ask the
questions but they're not waiting for me
they are waiting for like is Brad Pitt
getting off the plane is Tom Cruise
getting off the plane and then I come by
and they're not expecting me but they
know they got to ask me a question but
they're not prepared and they don't know
anything about my life because I have a
really boring life so they're always
saying things like do you floss
regularly then I know they bring that
back to TMZ and they're like oh the
sauce I only just don't say anything and
just make a face that's not usable you
know because I don't want them to use it
so you can't do anything so I just
whatever they say I'm saying the other
thing you can do is hum a tune that they
would have to pay for exactly it's
really expensive anything by Led
Zeppelin you can't clear it exactly the
music rights are through the charts
Beatles just start singing a Beatles
song all you need is love yeah what my
wife and we do when we were shooting
this is a movie in New York we would
just run right at them because they
expect you to run away but we would just
go straight to them
we have some of those yeah we have
pictures of you guys running
be great it'd be great if they started
running away like they do get scared
they get scared
you